hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter eight
of the categories Aristotle turns to a
very important type of way of talking
about things and actually
conceptualizing the world he thinks that
this connects with things that are
actually there in the world and he talks
about quality or poyo tastes in Greek or
topo I own now one of the main types of
quality that are classes of quality that
he talks about and gives some some
analysis to not a completely
comprehensive analysis that waits for
for other works he has to do with what
we call habits and dispositions the
Greek word for habit is hex ace this is
coming from the word to have or to hold
or to to you know make part of one's
possessions you might say and the word
for disposition is do thesis this is
coming from the word to put down and
it's it's kind of along the same lines
but we'll see how it's different so the
first thing I want to mention right off
the bat is that habits are all
dispositions according to Aristotle
so habits are a subclass of dispositions
but what this means is that
every habit is a disposition not every
disposition is a habit you have some
dispositions that are not habits other
dispositions that are habits
Aristotle actually devotes quite a bit
more discussion to habits and when we
think about the paradigm examples you'll
see why it's so important for him if you
think about his larger works where he's
interested say in ethics or or you know
politics or also in in metaphysics so
what's the difference between
dispositions and dispositions that are
not habits and dispositions that are
habits habits Aristotle says are longer
lasting and more stable and I put the
Greek terms up here because I want to
discuss them a little bit so
longer-lasting phroneo thrown this is
coming from the Greek word for time
Chronos the way that we get say you know
Cronus Cronus cope from right no I think
a clock or something those lines now
longer-lasting a habit is something that
extends through time that continues on
that's not going to you know end at a
certain point by its own nature once
it's established as a habit more stable
so Aristotle uses two terms here for
more stable one of these is is from is
it's moni moni motor neurone right and
this word he has to do is sort of
staying in place you know resisting
things pushing it out of its place
remaining is a way we could say do skin
altered our own so you see that would
connote a neuron right there kinases
change or movement is the core of that
deuce means something like you know
resisting in this case or not easy or
difficult so only moved with difficulty
would be a great way to translate
that so if you think about what habits
are like and we don't get into the ones
that Aristotle is describing here but we
think about something like a habit of
for example so let's say we take habits
that have to do with personal grooming
and hygiene you get yourself into the
habit of taking a shower every single
morning when you find yourself unable to
take a shower you're gonna feel a bit
weird and and like the day is off and
sometimes you may like get up and go and
take a shower without even realizing
that you know you're you're already into
your morning you know it's it's
something that would take some time to
develop of course but then once it does
it becomes very stable and just
continues on through time there's many
things that would you know sort of fit
into this having coffee in the morning
for myself right
I sometimes I'm not even thinking and in
a real sense until I have my coffee I'm
kind of on autopilot the habit is is
running the show they usually only get
you know woken up like there's no coffee
what am I going to do
right so habits are longer-lasting and
more stable this becomes a lot easier to
see when we look at the two paradigm
cases for what Aristotle talks about as
habits here so virtues audit audit I
write in Greek coming from the
superlative of goodness Agatha's virtues
are determinate kinds of goodnesses
usually moral goodness is but we can
also think about other things as well
like you know bodily form here he has
more in mind things like justice
temperance generosity all you know
great-souled miss though those sorts of
things that we label as virtues likewise
the vices determinate forms of badness
katia in greek coming from the word
Kakos which means bad right those are
also habits those are also hacks ace
hacks aces the plural of exes so those
fit in and we'll talk about that in a
moment
but then we also have knowledge and
notice I put it in the plural here
knowledge is or rather kinds of
knowledge so everything from being able
to play a tuba to being able to to you
know hang drywall to being able to talk
about Aristotle in some sort of
competent way all of those are types of
knowledge and there's many many other
types as well Aristotle loves to use
grammar as an example we'll try to stay
away from that in this this particular
video but knowledge is a habit it's
something that Aristotle says is not
easily displaced and he actually says
something quite interesting about this
he says knowledge is considering its
lasting and hard to displace from the
mind though a man may in fact have
acquired it in only a moderate measure
unless some great change should come
over him thanks to disease or the like
so let's take knowledge of Aristotle as
an example right once you actually learn
something about say Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics I use that as my
example because that's probably the text
that I have done the most work on over
the course of my career once you have
learned some of the basic ideas and
principles I think it's fairly and you
understand how they fit in with each
other and you can say you know reproduce
them on a test or in a paper later on so
they're stuck in your head and they're
not going to just fall out of your head
like once you've put it on the test
some people do kind of a brain dump
right that's not having a habit yet
walking away from the class and then
being able to talk about it competently
later on that would be the development
of habit
so understanding ethics according to
Aristotle's treatment of it in the nikah
mccann ethics not just you know the
field as a whole but that that
particular bit of knowledge well that
could be greater or lesser we don't say
that you don't have any knowledge
whatsoever if you don't know the text
inside and out so even if you only have
a moderate amount you do still have some
knowledge now if you were to damage the
person's brain who has that knowledge or
you know let's say they have a terrible
fever right and some parts of the brain
get you know damaged because of that
that's the sort of thing it might take
to wipe out a well-established habit as
a matter of fact we also see this with
with moral attributes as well virtues
and vices sometimes you know cases of
damage to the brain or you know even
trauma that occurs within a person's
life may steer them away from the virtue
that they have but but in in most cases
the virtue is established and it sort of
remains in place the same thing
unfortunately is the case for Vice so if
we take for example aero-sub Alexei you
know using justice and injustice here in
the category so justice is a habitual
disposition right to for example give
people what they are owed so to follow
through on paying debts and to do so and
you know over time and to do so as part
of you know your character there could
be some things that could impede you but
all things being equal the person who is
virtuous will as a virtue of justice is
going to pay his or her debts they may
need not even need to think about it in
some cases this is where people say well
that's a no-brainer oftentimes
when it comes to moral things people who
say that it's because that's become part
of their character and they've developed
it and they just don't realize that most
other people don't see things that way
or also they wouldn't say it's a
no-brainer because obviously other
people do have to think about it
like why is vice the person who's unjust
in the sense of say being greedy always
on the make always looking for how they
can turn a situation into pecuniary
advantage for themselves dan is going to
be stable that's going to be something
that you can rely upon them to do unless
something comes along and changes that
so you know if somebody goes to jail for
acts of greed because they were found
out unless something comes along to
change that you probably should in fact
Aristotle says expect them to continue
to act in the same manner if there is a
habit established now by contrast what
we're translating here is dispositions
or dieses those are Aristotle says
qualities that are easy to change and
the examples that he use are a little
bit hard to to get unless we sort of
think it through so for example he talks
about hotness and coldness something is
hot now so it's disposed in such a way
as to give off heat right but it can
easily become cold I'll give you two
examples one is your hot drink that you
order as you're going through the
drive-thru right at a fast-food
restaurant
take coffee for example now you know
they finally got the idea after that big
lawsuit that maybe we shouldn't
superheat coffee so that if it spills
and falls in somebody's laps they get
you know second and third degree burns
but it's still pretty hot with your kid
it isn't it right and it's too hot to
drink generally when you first get your
your coffee from some places but give it
a little while and it quickly loses that
and and after a while it gets the point
really
good right and then not too long after
that it's cold and if you I don't mind
cold coffee but some people really do or
a cold tea and they get get kind of
upset about that another great example
is let's say the human body right you
come in in a winter day from out of the
cold to the cabin where you're staying
and you go in front of the roaring fire
to wait Toto not wake up to warm up and
you're you're sitting there and you're
shivering and gradually the heat
permeates your body so the cold is is
you know gradually going it's it's
something that's pretty easy to to get
rid of and now you're sitting there and
you're like ah it's getting kind of hot
so you take off your hat and your coat
and your boots and you're sitting there
and now after a while you're pretty hot
and start sweating and you're like it's
getting too hot in here and so you go
and you open the window and it starts to
cool down a bit your body starts to cool
down there's a prime example of what
we're talking about Aristotle also uses
the example of disease you can be
diseased now and get healthy very
quickly provided it's not something you
know terminal or chronic you know like
say arthritis can be chronic it's not
going to quickly become healthy most
likely but you know think about it for
example a sinus infection right now back
in Aristotle's time before antibiotics
if you got a sinus infection you
probably we were going to have it for a
while and suffer now you go to the
doctor and the doctor says oh you got a
sinus infection here's some antibiotics
within a couple days it's probably
cleared up right unless there's other
issues well those are examples of what
Aristotle is calling dispositions the
last thing that we want to talk about
with respect to dispositions and habits
is that habits have contraries so for
example virtue teach virtue is opposed
at least one vice it gets a little
complicated with that and Aristotle
schema knowledge what's the opposite of
knowledge ignorance right so with
respect to Aristotle I have knowledge I
can teach you about it with respect
some you know aristotelian x'
from from the Islamic world
who I haven't studied I don't know
anything
I have ignorant about that right habits
also admit of degrees and this is kind
of important too so it's possible if we
take virtues right it's possible to be
more just or less just it's possible to
have a habit of justice but one person
to be more just than another person it's
also possible to be more unjust or less
unjust right and it's even possible to
be neither just nor unjust but somewhere
in the middle because you haven't
actually established a habit of justice
or injustice at this point in time
children are often in that sort of
malleable State adults typically will
have one or the other fairly developed
knowledge also admits of degrees and
brought up the example of Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics
I understand Aristotle's NIC and McCain
ethics pretty well so I have I have a
well established habit of knowledge
within my my mind you perhaps unless
you're an heiress level scholar may
understand it less well but still have a
habit developed in your mind with some
of the rudiments of that there are some
Aristotle scholars who I you know
particularly like to read and respect
who are way way beyond me when it comes
to their understanding of Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics perhaps so so much
further that you know beyond work I am
that we could do make a analogy I am to
them as the beginner is to me all of
these would be examples of degrees way
more and a less with respect to the
development of a habit in this case the
habit of knowledge of Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics so there is habit and
disposition